cat's here
hello hello cat's here what's up
okay cold open welcome back to big mood
i didn't get to be here when she was on
last year i mean i was here but i was in
the corner nikki's very excited to be
on camera with our newest favorite guest
mrs katie yeah yeah that's exactly how
you say it
we love her you might have seen her on
jk but she's most
known for being on something for a big
moment
the last episode i did i blew the [ __ ]
up same thing yeah thank you for having
me
back she's dating brad pitt now yes
okay so we left our favorite boyfriend
[Laughter]
yeah i bet he is um okay so you're
actually from
podcasts such as king and the sting king
and the sting and fighter in the game
spider-man
yes okay great well i think you're the
best one thank you
yeah yeah i'm on
only fans uh i recently started a
podcast
it's called i don't know when this comes
out but uh i'll just
be out two weeks about two weeks it's
called bandit
yeah instead of a you it's an x so what
what's the uh general idea for your show
um i honestly have no idea
um the whole i noticed that you guys are
matching nails
yeah i think so i don't know what and
then i have a color too
yeah i don't paint my nails because the
same goes with jeans jackets
jacket colored
[Laughter]
but i don't know what the podcast is i
just decided to do it one day
and i started recording i found a friend
who would help me
record because i'm terrible with like
the producer side of it
yeah i tried to upload vlogs before i
started doing only fans and then i kept
losing footage and so i gave up on that
oh yeah and so when i decided to do a
podcast i was like i need
somebody who's gonna do it because i'm
gonna lose every single thing i've
recorded
people don't understand like that it's
it's
multiple jobs so when it's a youtuber
doing everything like they're doing so
many people's jobs
that normally is just like a person's
whole job and you need that it's
so many different parts like staff or
help is definitely a big plus
that's cool so how many episodes do you
have or that will
as of right now i will have three or
four
okay so in a couple weeks there might be
like five or six by the time this comes
out so that's good that's a good check
i haven't launched it yet oh so when is
it launched
next week maybe you better follow it
follow the i don't know just uh follow
the socials you find out when it
launches yeah
i think it'll probably be like two weeks
at least we'll even tell you it's a
mystery you have to follow
yeah uh but yeah it's called bandit my
boyfriend came up with the name
yes he says that's i think the story is
something along the lines of we were up
at two in the morning
and that's when like i become a little
demon okay
okay
all right okay yeah thank you for being
here with your bag of dicks
um so we just we didn't really have
anything super prepped for a cat but um
we were like do you want to shoot the
[ __ ] or do you want to react to some
[ __ ] because we think it's fun to like
react to listicles and stuff so i
actually found this
listicle on buzzfeed and it's about
things that people secretly
judge others for like wow i am in a room
full of 30 year olds
she just said a listicle from buzzfeed
but
that's great because i feel like in my
soul i'm older than i actually am
because my favorite thing to do
on the weekends is my boyfriend i will
go to
the valley and look at houses like
window shop for houses on a scooter like
i'm on the front oh my god he's so cute
we're not
trying to buy a house we just like
looking at houses yeah so we'll have
lunch we'll have a coffee and then like
go around to neighborhoods before
somebody yells at us to get out
i love that so i secretly feel like i'm
actually older than i feel that from you
honestly just talking to you you have a
bigger maturity level
what's that term that the gen z calls
the millennials that like try too hard
you all remember that new term that just
chewy yeah
so i think chewy right so i think it's a
little chewy to be out to
to like be into like reading buzzfeed
listicles but you know what we're chuggy
and we're proud
[Laughter]
and this is our coming out story i'll
start if you drive a
um a pt cruiser oh
yeah the pt loser they don't even make
that car anymore right
i feel like i feel like whoever made
that car should
should be beat up i don't know i don't
like that car at all i think it's gross
i wouldn't bully you i can't even
picture it in my head it's really ugly
there's an episode of the office where
michael
pulls up in one and he says it's britney
[ __ ]
that's all i know it's the car shape so
weird because it's like smaller in the
front and then it gets boxier as it goes
to the towards the back it's just videos
it's a duck
oh duck it's like so we're pt cruisers
oh no
no that's not what i meant gina says
[Laughter]
and hhr cars up what's that hard
ugly you'll know when you look at it
it's the most maybe those cars that have
like if you just have a regular
honda or a toyota and you put the huge
spoilers on it mm-hmm
i'm like okay you street race we get it
okay
people have a double exhaust and a huge
spoiler yeah i like that but with these
cars
you like that no no yeah i come from
like my jdm background but okay
if it's like the pt cruiser the hr is
like all right i get it you gave up
you know oh god nobody gets a pizza
cruiser they end up with a pizza
you don't choose a pt cruise now life
gives you one yeah yeah
exactly part time see mine is when you
see g
wagons in la but then they have like
monster truck like off
on them almost like they're trying to be
though why are you taking that thing
i don't know but it's oh they're always
in glendale i don't know if it's like an
armenian
thing or it's just like upstairs you are
always in glendale yeah
you know they're definitely like where
you're parking this thing you live in an
apartment
oh so like first of all i hate bmw
drivers sorry jess
uw drivers are always one that cut
people off yeah
they have to they have all these
insecurities they gotta show them on the
road
but i just enjoy driving because it's a
[ __ ] driving machine bmw
drivers enjoyed it i do enjoy driving um
i have i live next to
so i live in a condo complex and it's a
shared garage
with a signed parking but the people
that park next to us have two
of the same exact bmw the one that you
used to have the same they have the suv
yeah they have the two of the same exact
ones i think ones is the parents the
ones is the
two boys that live there i don't know
that it's a
serious competition and it's white it's
white
yes to export it i'll take a picture of
you don't have any more
point first of all i hate being doubly
drivers but they
put a decal on it makes it so much okay
that's
pretty crappy so across the entire front
windshield it says
beamer boys
[Applause]
you have a small dick i know i can smell
it oh get it off it burns
oh y'all why do y'all gotta do that [ __ ]
steve and i love it
car eyelashes oh those are all like lips
they'll put it in like a [ __ ] what is
it a buggy
bug and then they'll put it on mini
coopers honestly any decals on cars i'm
not
just not okay first of all shout out to
my tasha people decals are cool
which one if you do it right which ones
like uh like like the jdm or like anime
ones those are sick
that's a whole culture behind that but
if it's like a d like if it's [ __ ]
eyelashes like you might as well just
tell people that you sell pyramid scheme
candles and oil business card on the
back window
yeah yeah it's like call this number if
you want to make serious cash
oh my god i hate when people put their
uh instagram handles on
a decal on the car yeah yeah i'm like is
anyone really doing that
right is anyone really following you
because they saw you driving around
it's like when twitter first happened
and all these businesses were like
follow us on twitter like no one's
[ __ ] following
your company on twitter sorry yeah do
people still use twitter
yes oh god yeah oh gina does it yeah
yeah
twitter's here oh dude
is coming for you nikki i don't know
i just know twitter is the place where
you can still have porn on there
oh right yeah i think that's why i
stopped using twitter because i get it
assaulted with it you know like it'll
just show up and it depends on who you
follow
yeah yeah okay so when okay i've been on
youtube
a long time is based on who you follow
right so i've been on youtube a long
time
and back in 2013 it wasn't it wasn't
like how it is now
and we did these follow back things
where it was like
fridays yeah first first a thousand
people to follow i will follow back
so i did that and that was eight years
ago and now those kids are growing up
and i don't know what they're doing
these kids is crazy
these kids are showing me that all over
you sit there and unfollow all those
people and i
don't want to worry i just don't twitter
just start a new don't tweet you start a
new twitter you guys remember that
follow back fridays and
throwback thursdays on instagram yeah
well i never did follow back fridays but
i did i don't know
i don't really care about myself
followers like oh you follow me of all
you that's like way
back then i remember the flashback
fridays and i thought that was so stupid
because you already have throwback
thursdays yeah exactly
it's just another reason to post enough
if you forgot to do the throwback
thursday then you go okay
flash my product and they're really just
like you posting photos of yourself
when you used to be at your peak cotton
that's really what it was like remember
what i used to look like oh i'm the
opposite i post when i was at my peak
ugliness in high school yeah you're a
little different
yeah you could [ __ ] load up so you go
the other way
yeah but um i was back on youtube in
2007 when we did sub for sub boxes and
people
are not sub for sub but box for box do
you even know what this is
so on actual youtube page like on your
channel's page
it says like channels you follow so like
you know there's like jk has like jk
party and jk films or whatever
and you would used to try to compete to
get in those people's boxes so
it was like a collaboration thing like
if you put me in your box i'll put you
in my box
so it's box for box oh it's like uh
myspace top ten yes
top eight oh it's like marketing would
that work
yeah back in the day it used to work um
it used to also work like if you like
each other's videos it would pop up at
people's feeds like
if i liked uh a big mood video it would
pop up in people's feet that video
and your subscribers would see the
things she liked so it's just another
way to get that's like all these
tick tock stars like faking
relationships now
like yeah cross contamination like yeah
cross contamination
i mean it happens with a celebs too like
it's crazy
but it's all marketing which
relationship do you think is like can i
play the fakest one yes
oh my god you've been dying for that
haven't you she's been sitting next to a
person without touching their hair
and play with my hair we're gonna fall
asleep it was too pretty she doesn't
like your hair so hers isn't that
because it was like amy schumer came out
recently and said that
she thought what uh the guy from a quiet
place and his wife
john krasinski yeah and uh emily were
like a publicity marriage
really i hope so i love him and then
but no they've been married for a while
haven't you yeah they have kids she's
just like i think she was just saying
some [ __ ]
yeah yeah i think she was there there
are hollywood marriages that are
pink obviously but i hear some i've
heard about the contracts
um but i i remember watching the office
you know because everybody loves jim and
and it's like he whoever he married that
girl got the biggest upgrade and then i
found out that he married emily blind i
was like oh
yeah he got the uh yeah
um but there's all these weird things
now where people are going back and be
like jim is actually the worst and i'm
like
okay pull the hate on whoever was the
favorite character
yeah i mean i get it like the characters
aren't perfect but
it's weird how also you do know it's a
show right yeah it becomes cliche
because they made it
cliche but like they were the original
so it's cliche now
yeah yeah i get it so there's some stuff
we could go through on this list i don't
know if
maybe they'll spark some more
interesting ones but um the first one is
pretty obvious it's like
um what the part of their life they're
posting on social media like it's to
like every tiny problem in their
relationship or something like that like
it's weird mostly facebook i feel like
people do that
but then you start to see it on
instagram and twitter and it's also
pretty weird can you give an example
i think it's like if um it's like those
people that overshare their relationship
issues and stuff
yeah you know oh yeah like the on and
off again relationships like
you have like the black scream and like
they're typing [ __ ] out like
oh do you know they're like sub tweeting
like don't trust at home
yeah yeah yeah there's a guess it's all
about who you follow
yeah there's this girl that i knew she's
like my favorite train wreck
your favorite train wreck like it's just
she i remember her
that should be an instagram handle yeah
my favorite train wreck and then people
like submit
i guess i don't know what the [ __ ]
happened but she was with this guy i
don't know
and then she posted a story like it's a
pov story so she's holding her camera
like this with a plate
and she goes this is what happens when
you cheat on a girl just start smashing
it i'm like so you're angry
destroying your own people and you
decide to grab a plate but bring out the
phone first so everyone can see right
exactly it's just like people record
themselves crying yes i can't do it i
can't
do that right yeah if you can pull out
your phone you're not
that sad yeah if you can pull out your
phone record yourself
okay and then post it if you're making a
video and you start to cry in the video
okay
i can kind of get behind that if it's
genuine like or if you if you
go hold on and you stop it and then you
come back or something like that but
the people that take pictures of
themselves crying that's really weird
i'm like
a lot of teenagers you were crying and
you pulled out a camera and took a
picture of yourself sad but like made
sure you stayed in frame like
stay sad this is the modern angsty mice
based here yeah that's really what it is
there's one uh this is when chester
bennington died and this girl posted a
few photos for her crying like
where's some piece chester bennington
she's like
oh my god like a slideshow of her
different angles of crying
have you ever seen those uh those videos
where people show themselves trying to
take the thumbnail picture
for their videos and so if it's a sad
one they're like they're like making
those faces but it's like
just them for like trying to get the
thumbnail mm-hmm
i get if you're making money off it yeah
but if you're just i'm sad
here's me smashing a plate yeah yeah
maybe you're trying to make money off of
it
not this one no no she has no plans for
that to [ __ ] expand
nope okay um here's another thing um
this is they're not all about just like
how people act on social media so this
one is just like um
this is what someone i will judge you if
you do this if people who gossip to me
about other people i always wonder what
they say about me behind my back oh for
sure that's true
i never actually think that though i
just think like oh my god they're so
funny i don't even think of other
people's lives ever like i mean
unless something actually happened where
i'm like oh my god did you hear what
happened to this person i really don't
like
look you know like i'm like i have too
many plants and too many cats
if you kind of meet someone and you're
kind of like in the beginning stages of
having some type of relationship with
them and they start gossiping
yes do you immediately go oh i can't
trust this person because i never really
think that way i just go like oh they're
giving me the t
it depends on who they're talking about
exactly and
how or like how private it is i guess
that could because if it was super
private i'd be like oh my god why are
you telling me this
exactly or if like the person if
someone's name got brought up and then
that person was like
oh my god i had an experience with that
person you know like i could see that
being okay
like because it's just like it it
triggered a memory that they had of that
person
they weren't like hey guess what so i
hate this person
some people do that though where you
just meet them they start to unload and
you're like
oh wow i didn't okay yeah yeah
like i didn't need to know all these
things but thank you i'm mickey by the
way yeah
maybe they're just like really need
attention or something
or they're just dying to gossip with
someone yeah my thing is uh
if you come to me and you say like yeah
all my exes are crazy
or i've lost all my friends you know
like yeah because of this
or like i i you know this whole group of
friends stopped talking me because you
know it's this person's fault or
whatever it's just like
that's something are you sure it's not
you are you sure it's not you if it's if
you've lost that many friends are you
sure
because i mean i can be a shitty person
but
no matter what drama i'm in especially
online why am i still here in the same
group
why am i still here in another group why
am i still here you know so that's what
i judge people on
i've met like i remember this guy dated
this girl
and she's like yeah i just lost all my
friends because i'm ex-boyfriend and
then we found out why we're like
there it is yeah because i broke up with
a guy who all of my friends were his
friends
because i moved out of state but i kept
half of his friends yeah
you know like if the breakup doesn't
have to mean you lose all of the friends
that you made just because they were his
friends first exactly
something happened yeah i really felt
like i lost every friend group but i
didn't talk about it i actually really
felt like it was my fault because like
i'm like okay well it must be me then
and then i had to go through lots of
therapy about it
but that's the difference because it's
like i wasn't telling everybody like
yeah and then this person bullied me and
this person believe me i was like
i don't know what i'm doing wrong what
did i do
help please you're just in la with a
bunch of clown chasers no this was in
santa barbara
okay yeah but yes there are a lot yeah i
do i do have
boundaries with people in la because yes
you don't know who to trust
you have to in l.a yeah you never know i
think that stereotype in l.a of like
people just kind of you don't really
have friends like you have very true
it's very difficult to look you up on
social media and see how many followers
decide whether or not they want to
yeah invest or prioritize you or they
like don't barely ever talk to you don't
return text
and then you blow up somehow like you
get on something and then all of a
sudden they're hitting you up all the
time it's like
or they weren't that big then they blow
up and ghost you yeah
that's another one that's happened quite
a bit happened to us for sure yeah
um you know i'll tell you what i was
trying to think of things i judge about
people because
i feel like i've always tried to become
more less less judgmental as time goes
on and i think that happens naturally
with
maturity and you learn things and you
can empathize with people and i always
think about like
oh well what if this happened to them
you know before like judging them on
their
outbursts that they have like what's
their background like that they had in
our hours like that
however i will [ __ ] judge you
if you cut me in line
don't [ __ ] cut me in line i hate that
so
what do you get i think it's the most
disrespectful thing tiff and i was just
at an event
and we had to stand in a line for a
[ __ ] photo for this thing
and people just kept cutting in front of
us and we weren't leaving a gap
there was no gap and we were first in
line like five times and they kept
[ __ ] why did you let them come back
they came with like a big group and then
they're the like photographer was with
them
and they like just started like and we
just tried to ruin their photo shoot a
couple of times because we were like
where i can take off my shoe and just
throw it into their shoes but yeah
yeah and then and then the group that's
in there will be like oh hey you guys
will take a picture too like that
longer yeah they're they're like they
yeah that's that [ __ ] l.a mentality
yeah
like everyone's the most important like
everyone's trying to get out of a place
and there's like a line and but people
come in from the sides and like cut in
it's like there's a [ __ ] line that's
just like a lack of common decency
exactly like it's entitlement yeah like
you just think that your
rules don't apply to you yeah that's
what happened to me at airports and this
one
uh at a restaurant we were waiting in
line to order food
we were in line and then our friends
came by and said hi we're like hey
what's up just a little bit of chit chat
while they were walking by
and the group behind us decided to go
right in front of us so we turned around
like what are you doing
and they're like well we're hungry and
i'm like oh so you think i'm standing
here just because
in this food line for fun yeah i'm
hungry too and then we made the move
back it's like what
makes you think that it's okay you know
like oh well you weren't paying
attention so you just cut in front of me
yeah so what am i like hey yeah so what
my favorite thing to do is i'll look at
the person
behind me and be like hey he got in
front of you too
tell him that you're more important than
him go ahead say it don't do it usually
yeah gina
yeah just just tell him that you're more
important than i get in my head
i think it in my head but i can't say it
i don't think
people really ever cut in front of me i
don't
feel like it's rare you've got an energy
of like like don't like
her don't you [ __ ] try it yeah the
lady's already judging me she's scoring
me i can't cut in front of her
they come up and i'm like you [ __ ]
try it you open with the bmw you don't
want to
carry you tear in your ass she's going
to cut me off later and drop in
no i gave up that i have a chevy now
okay oh chevy's
treat me like a chevy driver okay all
right guys now we're going to take a
quick break to
shout out our sponsors first up is
doordash
the food delivery app that provides uh
that connects you with restaurants
that you love right now and right to
your door and you can get
grocery essentials that you need with
doordash
you can get drinks snacks and other
household items delivered in under an
hour ordering is super easy you just
order you just open the doordash
app you choose what you want from where
you want and your items will be left
safely outside your door
with the contactless delivery drop-off
setting you know what i ordered recently
from doordash
what moving tape i can do that
i didn't have time i was busy packing
and i was like i need more moving tape
so i had them bring me two rolls of
moving tape from the cvs yeah yeah he
did it in under an hour
it was very fast it was like 15-20
minutes perfect
that's awesome yeah doordash is awesome
um with over 300
000 partners in the u.s puerto rico
canada and australia
you can support your neighborhood
go-to's or choose from your favorite
national restaurants like popeyes
chipotle
and cheesecake factory there we go
so for a limited time our listeners can
get 25 off
and zero delivery fees on their first
order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter code
mood that's 25 off
up to a 10 value and zero delivery fees
on your first order
when you download the doordash app in
the app store and enter code
mood don't forget that's code mood for
25 off your first order with doordash
subject to change terms apply hi i like
a clean butt do you like a clean butt i
like a clean butt butt
i love clean butt butts summer's here
and living ain't easy if you got swamp
ass
oh my god texas i love it texas swamp
ass
yeah i don't have swamps well get it
hello tushy how will you stay on top of
your sweaty butt butt
try a refreshing spray from a hello
tissue bidet
keep your sweaty crack clean all summer
long with the brand new
hello tishi 3.0 modern bidet attachment
it's a stylish eco-friendly refreshing
little shower for your ass
whoever it is we like them hello tissue
3.0 cleans
soggy butts like a chat but it doesn't
stop there it also cleans itself with
the smart spray automatic self-cleaning
nozzle
no one wants to work up a sweat in 100
degree heat that's why the hell tissue
bidet attaches to your existing toilet
with no
electricity or extra plumbing needed and
hello tissue cuts toilet paper use by 80
so it pays for itself in a few months
hella tissues got your ass covered with
a 60-day risk-free guarantee and a
12-month warranty
already got a hell of a tissue on this
on the pot treat your ass to the new 3.0
model
if you're new to the revolution join
millions of happy hello tishi
customers right now i have a clean butt
butt with every flush i like bidets
i feel like everyone should have a bidet
yeah after going to japan
i come back if i stay in someone's house
and have a bidet i just don't feel clean
you know like i always tell people
imagine if every poop that you take no
matter how like
like butt blaster diarrhea it is it's
only one wipe
you need to eat more fiber yeah yeah
but if you don't have enough fiber and i
hate sitting there wiping over and over
and over again
yeah the hella tissue you wipe once
because it cleans it with water
so defeat swamp ass go to hell
tissue.com big mood to get 10
off plus free shipping this is a special
offer for our listeners
it's hella tissue.com big mood for 10
off again that's hellatushy.com
big mood and clean your butt butt um
the next one if i go to use the bathroom
in someone's house it's crusty dusty
covered in hair and god knows what else
i will judge you
oh yeah i can't i don't trust anybody
who has a dirty
bathroom yeah i hate it like any time
i used to go on dates if i was at a
guy's apartment
and i went to his restroom if it was
dirty i just assume your dick is also
dirty yeah
like i'm not putting it in my mouth so
i'm touching my bathroom's messy
but like messy and dirty are two
different different like if there's
pubes and
stuff like having towels on the floor is
different from like
having a crust on the side of like your
toilet bowl
it's different yeah i could deal with a
mess i can't deal with dirt and muck
i judge one ply toilet paper right yeah
kind of like mars paper i just feel like
you have dirty fingers yeah
i know your finger breaks through it
mm-hmm well you could wrap it a lot
yeah i mean you if you have one ply then
you have to use twice as much okay
you calm down okay i do that though i do
that you have to double
you have to wrap a [ __ ] ton yeah you get
the one play but yeah i just assume you
stole it because no one has
what grocery store from a restaurant who
sells one pie that's all charmin at the
grocery store
you buy it yeah yeah the dollar store
dollar store yeah yeah like damn you
need to splurge for some toilet paper
come on
cause you're gonna end up using more
anyway yeah it's not really a deal it's
like when you buy cheap [ __ ] and you
have to
like replace it more often without
saving money but whatever
yeah people don't put their shopping
carts back
yeah i do it every time and i don't know
like sometimes i wonder where i draw the
line because i know i'm such a [ __ ]
role follower even though i'm kind of
like hardcore like crazy but like i
follow the rules a lot still too
and so i have to [ __ ] like when i
leave it somewhere i just feel like i
can it follows me feels like
for the day i'm just like why did i
leave it there i should have just walked
it back
the guilt yeah i'm like guilty before 30
i used to do the thing where you put
kind of put half of it over the curb
but after 30 i've changed okay good i
cleaned my house
now okay i organized my kitchen good for
you
yeah yes don't [ __ ] put your cart on
the curb i only do that if i can't find
the thing
oh yeah yeah yeah just looking around
like where the [ __ ] is this thing i want
to be able to
run i want to put her i go out of my way
because i don't want to beat that [ __ ]
oh i can't do it i can't do it it's just
it's just like
i think i think there was a study that
showed um how
human nature is like judging just by
the act of putting your cart back and it
just shows that people can never govern
themselves because this is the simplest
thing yeah
it sounds like a communist ad probably
it's kind of it's kind of like
i mean i don't know i'm kind of lazy
like if it's really far i'm like okay
if it's too far out but i won't be the
only one if there's other rogue shopping
carts i'm like okay they did it too
i'm taking that [ __ ] back i'm not gonna
be the first it makes me feel like oh
this neighborhood doesn't take care of
itself
and it just makes me feel like it's
trash unique they don't respect their
yeah like if you don't respect your area
that's what that's like one thing i love
about japan like because they're so
they're so militant
and there's obviously negative things
about how militant they are but like
for me as a an incomer like a visitor to
that country for everything to be so
clean and well taken care of and the
community just
like cleans up after itself and it's
just awesome it's like relaxing how
clean everything is so i just prefer
yep the community to take care of itself
i guess because i
it doesn't bother me that much because i
don't feel like i'm
perfect or like i feel like i'm kind of
a messy individual
inside so it kind of reflects out like
if everything's so you leave your trash
everywhere no no i don't i do not litter
like literally actually i'll judge you
for literally i don't [ __ ] litter
but um but like the you know like like
kind of like sloppiness like it's
like it's with the other shopping cart
that someone left there so
like they can be free okay yeah they're
friends it's like i'm not
making um it's not dirty it's not adding
to the chaos but you're not making the
chaos yeah exactly because if everything
was super neat and tidy like japan
like what you were saying i feel like
that would give me anxiety because i'm
like i could never hold up the standard
like
i'm gonna [ __ ] up because i'm just not
extremely tidy like this
like it's but it's so easy conscious
effort so if you take it there you can
put it away
it's not oh yeah yeah i mean if it's
like right there i'm gonna put the
shopping cart there
and i told you that after 30 i do it but
i don't think you have to feel like
you're a perfect feel like inside
i'm a shower i'm a shopping cart leaver
inside okay well i'm judging it's like a
conscious effort
to see going off of that i don't like
people who don't clean up after
themselves
like if you make a mess and then you
just leave it assuming somebody else is
going to come clean it up i
[ __ ] hate that okay but what if
someone's already collected them all
and then i'm like thank you that's picky
are you the person that throws trash on
the ground
i do not literally well you're like
literally it doesn't count as littering
shopping carts are just they're they're
just you're like this is why they have a
job i'm just going to leave it wherever
i want because
i want to just lose the job guys i'm
also the person that takes the shopping
cart like if i pull up and there's a
shopping cart someone left i take that
shopping cart
so it's not like i like i feel like
people could still take those shopping
carts
it's not like they're off limits okay
they're there
we're not judging you yeah it seems i'm
gonna get off my back
[ __ ] i no longer have a bmw
well i no longer do your shopping cart
cards i would buy another one though
in the future oh i might leave a shot
before
okay speaking of bmw drivers if you
speed up to block someone with their
turn signal on you will be judged
so like i guess if someone's trying to
get into your lane yeah and you kind of
don't let them in
i think there's a certain circumstance
where that's not okay and i will be like
no
[ __ ] you if they're cutting the line if
they're trying to lie
if i see them pulling like a [ __ ]
half a mile back and they try to cut
through all these cars i started getting
waiting as close as i can i'm like nope
you're not [ __ ] standing in front of
me and i cannot kiss if the person in
front of me that's the moment i'm like
why don't you
see them why'd you let them do that if
they speed up
to not let me in and i get in behind
them but there's still traffic in front
of you i'm like where did that take you
exactly where'd you go i will i kind of
get it
i get petty if they don't put their
signal on though like it's not that hard
put your signal i'll let you in
it's not that hard exactly it's super
cool get your [ __ ] brake lights
checked i hate when i'm driving behind a
car and their brake lights aren't
working and suddenly i'm like smashing
on the brake
like every three minutes because i don't
know what's happening yeah i hate that
oh my god it's illegal for a reason yes
i guess there's because there's so many
cars in california there's just like so
many beaters
yeah but i i hadn't really noticed that
too much
have one of them fixed at least one just
one at least one
that's all i ask for your safety and
mine this is kind of unrelated but
sparked a memory did you when you were a
kid
well obviously not you because you're
much younger but were you when we were
when you were a kid did you ever hear
that thing like if you see a car
with one headlight out then yeah it's
like a game and you punch someone or
something no
what oh no oh okay i remember there used
to be like some yeah
some sort of game like if you see a car
with one it's only driving with one
headlight then you like yell out a
phrase or something and then you
like punch someone kind of like a slug
bug no okay nevermind
that's just me what were you thinking of
oh i was thinking if they're
if they forgot to turn their lights on
and you flicked your headlights up oh
yeah but that could also mean there's
like a cop
in the other direction yeah and also i
heard it was like a gang initiation too
like first person to flick their lights
at you like you
beat them up or something so i stopped
doing that for people well
let's see bad table manners do y'all
care about bad tables
dude i went on a date with a guy once
and when it's
like this is how this is how we like we
cut
he told you or you this is what you're
saying i'm saying this is how we cut
steaks right okay
if you hold your [ __ ] like this steve
does that
her husband does that he's like a
caveman he doesn't need him i can't
stand that he fists his fork like
the sporks at the top yeah at the top
because he just chokes around it
oh he jokes before he scoops it we're
making fun of you honey we're making fun
of
you
that is like a mental illness i think
like he can't the toileness in it yes
like like
please hold the fork the normal way
every time i see him eat i'm like
he gets really upset when i try to
correct him because he's like i can't do
it
again like i feel like he's using a
spork and not a fork or a spoon he's
using a fork but scooping it like using
a fork but you don't even use a spoon
like that either
like a chocolate yeah he's like a child
yeah yeah
that's the most annoying thing about him
i think the odds
that's like that's not the only thing
that's the most annoying thing what's
other things i don't know there's other
things
about everybody there's anything else
about everyone that's the one thing
where i'm like
stop it i can't like don't eat with him
have you ever been on like a bad date oh
my god yes what is it
uh it was so i was seeing this guy like
on and off and he was like a booty call
and it got to a point where he was like
you know what let's try to go out on a
date
and so we went to go eat korean barbecue
and halfway through the day i realized i
didn't like him
and so i paid for half of it so that it
wouldn't like look like a date yeah feel
like a day
and afterwards i just i didn't want to
do any sex it ruined the sex from yeah
so afterwards we were gonna go hook up
i pretended to have like multiple
orgasms so like i would be done
and would leave you're like trying to
get him to hurry up because his
personality just like
runs like he was asking me these things
where i just i was like oh you and i
aren't compatible at all i want to leave
now this isn't
why did you go through with the hookah
guts i don't know i think
just hooking up like he was fine because
he was just like a dick and he and i
were like
friends so you assumed that after the
bad date it would be okay once you got
there and just i stopped talking to him
like right after
yeah but i [ __ ] him because it was
almost like assume that we were gonna
[ __ ] afterwards i was like you know what
this is the last one and then two
minutes in
i like faked a bunch of orgasms like wow
you're great tonight
and he came really quick because he
thought he was killing it and once we
left i never hit him up again
i was just like i can't remember what he
was asking you that like made you
it was like it was these weird things
where you know when somebody talks to
you and they're only really talking to
you so they can
share this and share their things it was
a lot of that
and then like him being rude to the wait
staff
i yeah like oh this is different because
like outside the bedroom you
like you're just you're not like a trash
person but like you're not great yeah
hasn't that been said so many times like
to not be rude
hasn't that been said so many times that
everyone knows not to do that
like how is it that people still do i
think he just didn't understand almost
like there
you treat people properly like he almost
seemed like he was like brought up with
this idea of like you're waiting on me
and so like if you want a tip you have
to work for it
yeah not like oh you do your job it's
like no i'm gonna make you work for it
tonight you know my friend's boyfriend
would never tip
and i was a waitress at that time like
and so i would that's so
it was i was so triggered and he would
be like well it's not like she sucked my
dick and i'm like
oh my god excuse me like
i just couldn't hand i was like i can't
go on double dates with you guys like
i can't be around your boyfriend oh my
god i can't believe somebody would say
that out loud like even if you
thought it why would you say it out loud
to others being funny
i'm like disgusting this one guy told me
like yeah my father always taught me
how you stay rich is never help homeless
people and i was like
what the heck how do you stay rich how
do you say how you stay rich is you
never help homeless people
that is not rich no because like giving
five dollars to someone like
four times a year doesn't change your
financial status yeah
come on unless you bought a lottery
ticket and you [ __ ] hit
but that's that's so stupid but yeah
like if you're rude to wait staff it's
done
it's no done deal it's such a [ __ ]
dryer upper
yeah because they're they're all about
like well it's their job i'm giving them
something to do [ __ ] you
i knew someone who's like because i
worked in service before so whenever i'm
done eating i stack my plates and i
clean up and just make it easy for them
and then this other person i knew was
like why would you do that it's their
job you know it's
because because someone be a dick you
just want to help people you know
dude i was telling someone because they
didn't get it and i was like
okay so in the state of california at
least um
if let's say no table ever tipped you
that night you lose you lose money
because the government assumes you're
getting tips so you at least get
10 of your sales are at least claimed in
taxes they want you to claim more
because they want you to claim all of
your tips
but if you don't claim anything they'll
minimum take
10 of whatever sales you sold that night
so you're basically paying for people to
eat dinner there if you don't tip
which is [ __ ] awful and then um
people
will give the argument like well it's
not my fault that's the job they chose
and it's like
no but this is part of the job like it's
just assumed like that's
so they don't want restaurants to exist
exactly well they should unionize okay
even if they okay let's say
they're unionized that's gonna take a
while so yeah
you're just being a dick in the meantime
because you don't have him it's hard for
a union to like be formed especially
because it's like
one restaurant versus another restaurant
yeah it's not like a whole industry
people just are
have have these go-to responses because
they don't want a tip because they're
shitty
yeah or i mean the problem is obviously
not the victim
you know which is the person with the
job exactly
i just can't oh that pisses me off
sometimes when like they didn't really
like it's a to-go order and they like
didn't really do
anything like it sometimes if it's to go
order i'll give them like 10 bucks if
they were super nice or
if i came in super late or something i'm
like oh here's 10 bucks like i'm kind of
inconveniencing you because it's like
almost time to close or
you went out of your way to be
courteously you know to me as a customer
but like sometimes where i'm just like
or if it's like a
fast casual restaurant like a [ __ ]
chipotle or something i'm like you don't
why do you need a tip like that's weird
you know
but for the most part yeah yeah if it's
someone waiting on you yeah
so uh everybody needs some help up in
here
and you can get help that's not
expensive with talkspace so we i
wholeheartedly recommend talkspace for
therapy
you can sign up online and start therapy
the same day as you sign up
you can text video or send voice
messages to your licensed therapist
and also i like that if you don't like
the one you get you can switch it out
like it's not a
huge process it's really easy yeah it's
very easy to switch it out
find one that you really like that
you're really comfortable with they're
all licensed
licensed therapists so it's incredibly
convenient to have virtual sessions from
the comfort of your home
instead of waiting for an appointment
you can send unlimited messages to your
therapist 24 7 and they'll engage with
you daily five days a week which is
really convenient because like if you're
having
some sort of anxiety attack or some
panic issue like in the middle of the
week you don't have to wait till your
session
your weekly session you can just text
them right away and they'll be there to
support you
uh there's a whole therapist network
that i was telling you about and it's
super secure
start feeling better with a single
message match with a licensed therapist
when you go to talkspace.com and get a
hundred dollars off your first month
with the promo code
mood that's 100 off when you use code
mood at talkspace.com that's a lot of
doll hairs a lot of doll hairs probably
one of the biggest discounts we have
yeah for sure
have you ever had an acne breakout at
the worst possible time
i always get them like monthly with my
yes period but then also if i try new
products i get them and then sometimes i
just like haven't been washing my face
enough
and so i get them the mask knee yeah oh
the mask
definitely got that i've been vaccinated
so i'm not wearing my mask as much
lately my skin's slowly kind of
coming back but if you are still having
some acne issues you should
try apostrophe their prescription skin
care
they offer science-backed oral and
topical medications that are clinically
proven to help clear acne
apostrophe connects you with
board-certified dermatologists who will
create a personalized treatment plan
that is perfectly tailored to your
unique skin
you simply fill out an online quiz about
your skin goals and medical history
snap a few selfies and a dermatologist
will create a customized treatment plan
they can also help you hit your skincare
goals like reducing redness wrinkles and
even dark spots
me personally i have some wrinkles so
you know
this old ass skin needs some help
it looks great i don't think you have
any wrinkles at all i don't see them
yeah well we're really far away from the
camera so hopefully you guys can't see
them either
we have a special deal girl okay we have
a special offer for our audience
save 15 off your first visit with a
board certified dermatologist at
apostrophe.com
big mood when you use our code big mood
this code is only available to our
listeners to get started just go to
apostrophe dot com slash big mood and
click begin visit
then use our code big mood at sign up
you'll get fifteen dollars off your
dermatology visit
that's apostrophe spelled
a-p-o-s-t-r-o-p-h-e
dot com slash big mood and use the code
big mood to get your dermatology visit
and save 15
we thank apostrophe for sponsoring the
podcast how do you feel about tipping
delivery drivers
i always tip delivery i have a minimum
of five dollars unless they
i had this one guy one time he delivered
to my apartment but he was drunk or
something
and he was with his friend and then they
were like yelling and
like they were yelling out loud like
being drunk like teenagers
yeah and then they handed me my food and
then they peeled out in front of me and
i was like
no tip no tip i don't want you in my
[ __ ] neighborhood like you shouldn't
even have this job
so that's the only time i remember
specifically being like no [ __ ] tip
or if the the driver is like
specifically an [ __ ] to me when he
shows up
like i couldn't find your [ __ ] place
you know and i was just like
okay bro yeah don't talk to me like that
don't [ __ ] talk to me
so before the pandemic i was like a five
dollar standard like that's how i was
raised
always like five bucks no matter what
like it was just it's five bucks because
that's
how delivery was yeah but then during
the pandemic they were like
actual lifesavers because we couldn't go
anywhere we couldn't go to restaurants
we couldn't leave our house or anything
so
i took 25 every time and then now it's
like i stayed at like a 20
15 to 20 percent level yeah yeah but
plus as you make
you get older and you make a little bit
more money it's easier it's easier to
like
because you know that if you tip three
dollars or if you tip seven dollars
that it's not going to really affect
your personal finances that much but
like that seven dollars would mean a lot
more to that like
person exactly struggling than it does
to your wallet plus i watch these tick
tock videos of how they get paid and
like
they do not make a lot of money like
they they rely on those tips so yeah
yeah like do you want that service to
still exist and that person to still be
exactly that's how you think about it do
i want this service to still exist yeah
yes i do it makes my life more
convenient so
yeah they need to be able to keep people
doing that service so
is it like a rant do you like it do you
have like a random thing that you judge
people on just random
random uh if you don't know how to do
dishes properly oh
that's another thing because like that's
one that my brother does not know how to
[ __ ] do how does your dude because
like he
rinses it and he'll have a wash rag
he'll put some soap and
a quick like swoop in the back you know
like when it dries and you see like that
film of like food that was still there
like the oil
like you can put your finger and there's
like a streak yeah i just tell them
don't touch the dishes yeah i will do
them
don't touch on purpose you take out the
trash you buy water and i will take care
of the dishes
that's it like do not [ __ ] touch my
dishes that
so you know that was one of the first
fights stephen i ever had
um i love listening to y'all's fights
because i'm like yes you're not perfect
we tell people all the time like we're
not we fight about things but we just
it's how you resolve it
so um it's just because he's so stubborn
that i was like
i'm doing the dishes for now and he's
like no i could i know how this is how
peop some people do the dishes no it's
not this is how
he did it so he would take a plate he
takes the soap
he drizzles the soap all over the place
a sponge and he just kind of goes like
this and then he rinses it all the soap
off oh my god
it's still like in the gel form it's not
lathered at all nothing and then that's
it that's how he washes that's the only
caveman who's and i
was like dishes being washed this is not
how you wash it he's like there's more
than one way to wash dishes and i was
like
that's not how your mom washes dishes
that's not how anyone watching nobody
washes dishes like that
and he's like yeah don't bring my mom
into this this is when we were first
dating
so like he would never we would never
fight like this now but like
before he was like don't bring my mom
into this i'm like i want you to wash
the dish like that in front of your mom
and you tell me that she approves of
that you tell me that she improves a bit
so i don't even wash a lot of you
literally never washed a dish before
he was so stubborn oh my god this guy's
stubbornness he's he's buying like
seven times i think he was embarrassed
he was probably embarrassed and he was
like just trying to fight it
yeah because he was cause i was calling
him out so hard he doesn't like it when
he gets embarrassed no he's not
he's very good um not very often but he
doesn't like when
it's something that should be common
sense
or like everyone you can dunk on him
really hard he just like gets
embarrassed because he wants to do a
good job and he wants to do it right and
to his credit he always tries to improve
he always tries to learn and get better
but i think because the way that i
called him out which now i know the way
to call him out now is not
so in the face like blatantly like
that's how you're washing dishes are you
serious
yeah it's more gentle like hey
oh that's weird that you wash it though
like you know how i wash it is like this
or something like that like if you get
you know if you get the lather
it like actually helps a lot i mean try
it that way yeah
more gentle not so like gasps but yeah
if you just come
at him he will hold on to that and he
will not let his
wrong way go and he will he like doubles
down yeah
he's the 100 double down guy
see that's my favorite thing about
having a boyfriend from the east coast
they just like have a higher tolerance
for like people yelling and like
[ __ ]
so i think i need to date a guy from the
east coast so i can throw whatever at
him i'll call him a little [ __ ] and
stuff like that and he'll just laugh it
off he loves it he eats that [ __ ] up
and so i can critique him on anything in
like the most
like foul basically abrasive way and be
super rude about it
and he just laughs it off and he
genuinely is like oh that's great
yeah whereas before everyone was like
every guy i
dated before that i felt like i had to
be very sensitive because they were like
very fragile when it comes to
critiques and with him i'm just like you
[ __ ] dumbass
yeah did you call me
and i'm like are you excited
i'm trying to think of something i think
i feel like i'm very judgmental but
i don't know am i it's like hard no you
me
never i'm struggling to think of
something
people don't i think the list of what
you wouldn't judge people for yeah
yeah i'm like where do i start people
don't wrangle their kids
yeah i've i've yelled at kids like i've
yeah they're like oh
they're being sassy they're being cute
like it's not cute
especially if you're a waitress and like
you're the kids are just
messing up the entire tables like i have
to clean that great yeah
and then they'll leave us six dollars
kids they dump all the salt out on the
table
they're opening sugar packets i'm like
oh my god like yeah
my mom would slap me if i did that yeah
that's really embarrassing
in vietnamese on an airplane once oh my
god vietnamese people always do that
[ __ ] did he speak vietnamese
yeah it was a it was a plane to japan
and for some reason
vietnamese people and there's this
[ __ ] kid that kept running up and
down would you say i want to hear it
um oh
what does that mean do you know what
that means uh it's basically like sit
your ass down before i beat the [ __ ] out
of you
and then and then his dad went oh thank
you
see vietnamese people are like see you
[ __ ] up they encourage it they love it
when strangers discipline their kids
they're like yeah if you don't
act right i'm gonna let you go home with
her yeah it's like a community thing
yeah
that's great whereas like like white
people with like the other kids like how
dare you yell at my angels that's a
certain kind of white people but yeah
for sure karen
there's a little like there's a while
they're like suffocating their cat
exactly
yeah no it's just like i feel like
parents who are very
quick to say like oh you don't know my
child and they're clearly acting out
the kids are like little demons yeah
like what are you doing yeah
that reminds me this [ __ ] like there
was that story yeah that
13 year old kid messaged me like hey let
me see your tits oh so i found his mom
and i messaged her and i was like i
screenshotted and sent her i'm like hey
uh your son's messaging some really
interesting stuff and
i think you should really monitor his
internet use because that's not okay she
goes
okay i i under you know yes my son did
something wrong but don't you ever tell
me how to raise my children
i was like [ __ ] [ __ ] you no wonder he's
doing that [ __ ] yeah exactly how dare
you tell me to raise my shut the [ __ ] up
like maybe if you did raise your kids
you wouldn't go to random strangers at
13 saying let me see your tits
yeah oh my goodness jesus christ yeah
that's just her insecurity because she
realized she has she's that's her steve
moment
that's what she's like doubling down
doubling down in her kid her 13 year old
[ __ ] subscription to pornhub
exclusive
oh god yeah hmm what's another good one
a juicy one jess give us a juicy one
what do you judge people for
if you're a man if you haven't and
that's it
[Music]
um like if people aren't they don't have
clean homes
i feel like you judge maybe why really
yeah
why just because i have a clean home i
touch other people yeah that's your
assumption
yeah you're putting you're projecting
that i am projecting i make sure my
house is like clean but i know it's not
as clean as your house and i'm like
she's gonna know she's gonna know she's
gonna
touch her dust you know i drink like
[ __ ] white trash as [ __ ] right
yeah but but you talked about how like
things could be even cleaner with your
dust method and i was like
i've never dusted my life oh we actually
talked about this uh before we start
recording people who don't know how to
say no and they're going to cancel on
plans anyways
oh my god the l.a thing yeah so yeah
we're not
going to show up but yeah and then they
don't yeah they know
yeah yeah or like do you know you
weren't going to show up we've had a
couple people were like would you like
to come on our show and they're like
yeah sure and then we try to
try to book them a couple of times in a
row yeah
yeah and then they don't show up and
then they they're just like oh i'm so
sorry
um yeah i'm just i'm the worst like oops
my bad you know and i'm just like [ __ ]
just say you don't want to come on the
show
they try to play it off like
[Music]
yeah so same with friends that are
not friends but acquaintance friends
like friends in la where you're like
yeah we're all going to hang out this
day we're going to grab lunch
oh no i'm busy now yeah yeah
it's like let's do lunch and then we
don't talk for seven weeks disney adults
disney adults people that are obsessed
with disney harry potter adults
but your life doesn't revolve around
there's a difference between
people that like disney flipped me off
in the shape of a d
she's the one she signed it
she's like i'm tiffany and this is the
disney channel dude with a big [ __ ]
middle finger same thing with nightmare
before christmas adults
oh there's not so many of those those
adults are so specific and so
into it yeah too much yeah it's like i
understand if you like it
but it's like i want a disney themed
wedding it's like all right calm down
yeah that's way too much
you know i i was watching um a youtube
channel what's his name curtis connor he
did a whole thing on disney adults and
there was actually like
a neighborhood that was built by disney
so they're like disney mansions
tiff is nodding you know about this it's
in florida there's disney mansions and
so they're like it's like a housing
community you could buy a house
crazy it was a dream that i inherited a
in a disney house community but i didn't
even know that existed
yeah that's really crazy they have like
little fountains with like [ __ ]
mickey on them
like it's just ugly it's trashy yeah it
my like
house that i inherited in my dream had
like a disney balcony
with like a rapunzel balcony yeah and it
was like super dude and i was like wow i
wonder how much this is worth because
i'm never gonna use this they're like a
million dollar mansions but they're
like so yeah
like toontown houses i mean they're they
like try to make them like
cool or whatever but it's oh my god
there's a murder
course tip says there's a ton of so
maybe we should google that
celebration okay well you guys if you're
interested in this in the really [ __ ]
weird disney the baby house has shooters
out here
yeah because i was talking to my friends
about like how like dude there's like
crazy disney adults who
they have to collect every pin yeah and
the ears i know some
and then there's there was starting they
were starting like
gang wars between like the pin community
like one community
that is just too much yeah they will go
in a group and then another one go in a
group they'll just mean mug each other
it's like if i ever get shaded by a
disney gang
i'm going to kill someone i think that's
something you rip off their pin
right like what the [ __ ] are you gonna
do to me you know so it became a problem
where disney had to like regulate
and [ __ ] like that's my gosh i think
that's something i judge people for when
like
something specific like that becomes
your whole personality i'm from new york
we don't do that in new york from new
york we don't do that i'm from new york
like that yes it becomes their whole
entire personality oh yeah well yeah
just
yeah pretty much anything and that that
even goes so far as to like being
obsessed with like any type of group
even like religion
or like politics or like where it just
feels like that because
it's your identity it's not like you're
you're like foregoing creating a
personality by just
just letting whatever the group does
that's like what you decide yeah like
people who
like there's still people now who are
still so obsessed with like trump or
whatever or anti-trump people and i'm
just like
there's more to life than that yeah like
why is that still
such a thing that couple of your houses
there's a couple that had a
trump-themed wedding what oh how do you
even do
just like based off of that wigs and
stuff like that i couldn't even do that
like trump banners her dress had trump
20 20 on it like
weird right like if i go to a wedding
if you have a politician politician like
yeah like
hillary
what are we doing here or like i've saw
i've seen in texas
i was like at a walmart and i saw this
guy had the letters trump like real big
as the decal on the back of his car and
i'm like
why are you so obsessed with this man
but yeah
like there's on both sides like people
that are obsessed with hating him too
like yeah that that becomes our identity
where it's like like there's other
elections
yeah i don't know super weird yeah
anyone that
gets obsessed super obsessed and makes i
guess like you know if you're like
obsessed with a rapper or something like
that sucks
yeah that's really [ __ ] like a
moderator i absolutely judge nikki for
being obsessed with eminem
people that moderated like yeah they're
foreign
very cringey people who are obsessed
with their pets oh right
yeah there's a certain obsession that
they're like certain like dog people and
cat people that i'm just not with
yeah where they're like too many like if
they have like so many cats like
yeah like more than three cats more than
five
more than three cats is like really
creepy my mom was like
my mom is like obsessed with her my
actual birth mom's obsessed with her
little dog where
she asked my little sister to skip out
on my aunt's wedding so that she can
watch her dog hey can you watch it out
for me while i go to auntie's wedding
what my sister's like uh-huh no i'm
going i'm going to the same way
she's like well yeah could you stay home
and watch a dog no
put her put it in a pet hotel and no i
don't trust those people
or like if we're hanging out outside we
don't want the dolphin i'm like mom why
don't you just
tie the dog to a leash to a tree she's
like i don't tie him to a tree he's my
son
okay dog yeah you know and i remember my
sister and i took the dog to
um go like grocery shopping whatever in
the middle of the night we just wanted
snacks
and um both of our phones are on silent
and she blew up our phones
when she came home didn't see the dog
she's like where's my dog i'm like hey
mom i'm okay too
oh god yeah her first thing is like
where's the dog yeah
so people like that are just yeah too
much
too much you're cool though nicki
no i'm not
i have a lot of cats see having a lot of
them i think is different from having an
obsession with them right right like
that's your referee like when you make
when you wear
they're not your identity you just
happen to have like
a jewelry line coming out cause kittens
and coffee and like we have cat and
crystal
yeah nexus yeah i judge people that are
so obsessed with their
their um astrology too right
oh that's like another yeah yeah yeah
see like i think it's so fun
yeah but like when people when you read
like i'll read it every now and then for
fun too
but yeah when they're like literally oh
this is a thing like this is and then oh
you're not going to work out because of
this thing and
i love it when it's like a leo is being
a leo and i'm like that's so
leo but not if like i can't help it i'm
a leona
help it it's an excuse for this yeah
yeah i mean even people who bring it up
like in passing i'm like oh i'm judging
you but i'm like it's i get it because
it's fun i still in my head i go
but but i'm like i'll play along a
little bit see i think it's fun to play
with whatever like i like um knowing a
little bit about everything so
whatever someone else's interest is i
just like almost chameleon into like
oh i know a little bit about that i can
like play with whatever your world is
because i just think people are fun if
they're different and interesting like
if you have an interest
i'm not going to judge you right because
that makes you interesting like it's not
but if they kind of take it a little bit
as as like fact
then i'm like oh if they try to like
argue modern medicine or something maybe
but yeah it's coming up wait you're well
birthday's coming you're what uh i'm a
cancer
me too what day uh july 3rd
oh nice when i was like when i was a kid
my dad used to lie to me and say that
the reason why their fireworks
on the fourth is because i was born on
the third it was like celebration the
next day
which is like cute now that i'm adult
but i with my whole last chest
went to class one day and they were
trying to teach about my independence
my teacher was like okay kid so do you
guys know what the fourth of july is why
we have celebration i was like
i know
[Applause]
it's my birthday that's pretty good i've
been so adorable on that show the kids
say the darnest things like if you just
whip that out
and the teacher thought it was sweet and
then there was like that one the like
classroom cloud like no the [ __ ] it is
yeah he said he kind of set you up and
then i ran back home after school
crying like it's not for me
i'm not special he's like they're
[ __ ] lying oh he's white
people don't want you to know i was like
no the kid
the kid who said it wasn't because my
brother he wasn't white he was asian
like me
then what are they saying yeah you like
don't listen to them that's so sad
i know and now i'm scored forever you're
like i don't celebrate fourth of july i
think
like he couldn't deal with you being let
down so he had to double down and that
that's what makes it makes it so cute
that he kept doubling down because he
was so embarrassed of like how proud i
was
like you guys would never [ __ ]
believe it you have the girl
and his birthday here yeah i am here
gracie i can tell you about this holiday
because it's me yeah
oh my gosh i got this one teacher sit
down i got it
i'm here do you want me to walk to the
front of class and tell everyone yeah
give me a textbook i'm in the textbook
right yeah that's cute i love that
well dude that hour flew by already
there's a huge list of things that jess
could judge people i mean yeah i'm like
where do i
start i mean i mean obviously like i
know that i should be judged for
plenty of things sure well that they say
that like the things you judge other
people for
it's like deep down like something that
you have that you've tried to combat
your whole life you know like
i don't know i don't talk on
speakerphone out loud in public yeah
i'm not rude to people [ __ ] that yeah
i'm not rude to waiters i don't know
i'm not dirty or play their music loud
in public
yeah oh my god i hate that dude there's
this guy so i lived next to a parking
lot of the other
complex and there's a dude that he
washes the car every
saturday every time when they watch the
[ __ ] car and he laughs his music
every time blasts it like a [ __ ]
concert and it's
acoustic in there because like it's like
a it's like a stadium
you know but it's so loud what type of
music is it
mexican covers of american songs
it's like oldies music but mexican
no dude i hate when it's rap music
because that's so annoying to me like
this guy
literally when i just moved into my new
apartment my dad was walking with me up
the stairs and this guy was detailing
someone else's car
i guess like he had his car i guess he's
maybe a mobile detailer whatever but he
was blasting rap music and i was like
bro you're white what are you doing like
why
you're trying to be so cool in the
parking lot you're just so hard with
your rap music
when i was a high schooler i used to
blast a like death metal though on the
like i just thought it was so cool why
do people think we want to hear their
music like everyone likes their
own music no one likes your music but
not
after high school i was like oh god it's
cringy to blast your music out in public
in my opinion like no one's going to
pass by and be like wow you have great
taste of music yeah yeah
what song is that dude
hold on especially when it's country
music
you get a little itchy no but i won't
because i'm in austin
oh i can go on with this list forever
because i can judge people all the time
wow
but unfortunately we're out of time yes
we are out of time
most of this was like i was on the list
yep
josh but hey we're so good we still look
like i'm really nice to wait staff yeah
that's what counts yeah
i would shoot fireworks for you on your
birthday oh i still believe this i'm
gonna think of you
when there's you in those fireworks
you're just one lonely sparkler like
imagine we text her these ain't for you
[ __ ] every single july
every year now it's not yours i can't
deal with the pain
just letting you know exactly my
boyfriend says it is
cute well anyway follow kat she's got a
new podcast coming out [ __ ] bandit
[ __ ] banned it
uh it should be out now it's out now if
i didn't lose a shot check it out
someone else is handling that job so uh
also instagram
only fans all that [ __ ] check out our
only fans it's really [ __ ] good
yeah it's fun it's fun don't look at her
if you
don't look at my butt or do if you pay a
little bit yeah if you pay you can look
at her butt
and you can look at her back but thanks
for having me guys coming back dude
i love having you
my energy and my spirit like blossoms
when i'm around other girls yeah
welcome like cool girl only cool girls
right yeah
i'm cool girl
all righty guys